um he always is talking about you
[ __ ] talking some [ __ ] said some
punk ass [ __ ] critics were talking
about but I gotta be able to get this
that's woody um cuz aaron has those
jokes were like he says it and I think
about it and then I'm like hilarious
it's like wait yes actually yeah that is
funny that's right i'm ryan right and
i'm gerry manoharan welcome to reasons
to see where we give you reasons to see
and not the [ __ ] see Elysium so let's
get the [ __ ] alicia reason to see
number one the story it's well-written
and it had the rare all is lost moment
where I was like damn all is really
really is we lost everything is I cannot
you need their him yeah it is kind of
like that that almost nightmarish
version the future where everything is
automated you know yes or no answer to
every question that Deena's parole
officer is like the inflatable speaker
at a at a [ __ ] fast food restaurant
that dispenses sedatives if you're
getting too pissy all the story points
hit and it moves in a very logical way
and there are certain things that could
even be cliche but the way he wrote this
out everything makes sense and you get
why everything happens and it's really
tightly wound together like the stuff we
do get to see as a story is really dying
the one complaint about as far as the
the pacing and everything is that fight
the final say half an hour things are
moving so fast and are going so loud you
don't really feel that there's a whole
lot of breathing space it's just like
the movie is this kind of melody of [ __ ]
going wrong into everything going
pear-shaped and just like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
anybody that lasts like 30 minutes just
like this long drawn-out prolong far
as everything's like getting more and
more tense and more and more
white-knuckle here's what I have to say
okay I [ __ ] love this story and bass
up with your Sam real fast I actually
took it as like it was a it was a
science-fiction thriller that was a
build up one of those kind of action
movies had built up for that
specifically the finale anyway up for me
like I just really took this as like a
[ __ ] like a really fun science fiction
action thriller you know fun in a
different way because it's actually
going is pretty dramatic a lot of the
time but yeah but it's always engaging
it's always thrilling yeah Matt Damon is
the last white person left in Los
Angeles yeah that's what this movie
taught me is that matt gaines it's gonna
be this is the last white guy in the
barrio the thing is the barrio is now
the entire LA County yeah like you see
those opening shots of what Los Angeles
looks like in it's just like this
constant slum that goes on to the
[ __ ] rice Greater Los Angeles bari is
how a life is today if you think about
it just a lot more heightened some
critics are saying how like it's about
these political themes in the first 45
minutes and after that they just don't
care about it anymore new to me I'm like
no it's much more than just the
political messages and the themes going
on it humanizes the political stuff
really well what I'd love to is like
he's taking all kinds of elements you
know he like we were talking about in
the car right um can you lift some of
them you have these sort of parallel to
our world you know you have you know the
haves and have-nots you know like the
separation between the wealthy and the
poor you have things like immigration
and healthcare and all that so elevating
[ __ ] in the world today it takes them
to an extreme so I guess it's easy to
view this as like it's beating you in
the face with its political message but
I didn't read it that way just because
it's that the conceit of their world
yeah it's a it's a social sci fi movie
in that it's a science fiction movie
about pertinent current day social
themes it's not too much of that that it
can also be a blockbuster it's a very
happy your cake and eat it too and yeah
at the end of the day to me this is much
more of a science fiction thriller than
a strong message this guy's trying to
communicate what I got both you know it
does have a strong message my message is
pretty strong it's about people living
in that situation yeah
just saying at the end of the day like
even if you're not there for the message
you're gonna have a great [ __ ] time
regardless and if you aren't there for
the message okay I'm pretty good time
too yeah cuz shut up you like seeing
[ __ ] blow up to right right one blow up
is cool sometime yes I'm sure you're
making this awkward reason to see number
two the directing who could new brew
come from yeah they're so [ __ ] sick
control homeboys back then I don't know
be the sitcom but he is back finally I
love everything he decided to do with
this film he really captured a world
yeah you know like a universe see you
know like I kind of feel like you know
in a way it's kind of like part of this
like district 9 universe or something
like yeah because it's a neill blomkamp
universe because if you've seen you know
his shorts and or even just district
nine you can there is a design and there
is a look that is sort of a through line
throughout a lot of this def feel him
composing pretty much throughout the
whole movie I was like this really is
your voice man and no one shoots [ __ ]
establishing jobs like this kind of
death he can pull off us the Sun the
crazy sci-fi cool stuff and then he
could pull off intense [ __ ] action
where there's real drama being felt in
an action scene and he could pull off
just a great human drama a just
everything he can do he can execute so
much there's no point where his action
is wantin or or you know pornographic
pornographic or just indulgent
everything is imbued with that that very
strong like you know this is part of a
story this is part of a narrative this
is taking people from you know point a
to a very dramatically different point Z
he can pull some pretty damn good
performances out of people he seems to
really understand his characters the
good reason to sing about three months
for matt damon bro matt damon yeah your
name is so cool it's so cool Matt de la
is like he's one of the few people who
can make looking like having a crappy
day look still really good and really
authentic this is he's so nice looking
like he looks like a nice guy but he can
also be like a total [ __ ] bad season
he's a nice guy you wouldn't want to get
on the bad side
this is if you did you know he's Gary he
he plays an ex-con so he's got that edge
to him he's got that that worldliness to
he's an ex-con that's working out as a
machinist in a company that builds cops
solid all around yeah I felt all the
emotions that guy was genuinely affected
yeah it really doesn't move you a man
damn gonna do the action man you can
[ __ ] do action he's like one of those
people who freaks out in an accident
scene and you're like good some more
intense cuz you're freaking out yeah
it's like you it's not like you think
this guy's just being a [ __ ] it's just
like oh I should be freaked out because
he's freaked out it is one of those
movies where like a regular kind of
regular guy has to do impossible [ __ ]
where it doesn't seem like how did he
learn to do any of it like you really
believe well yeah cuz yes God he had a
rough and tumble background he grew up
on the streets moan you when you know
side you first see Matt Damon just like
there's a whole history like emblazoned
on this guy and Matt Damon fills those
shoes really [ __ ] brilliantly you can
feel a history already faced off just
looking into those beautiful blue eyes
you can feel his feet you could feel
another shoes yeah I want to feel his
feet I would give Matt Damon a foot
massage reason to see number four
sharlto copley this dude is a scene
stealer yeah I every time he was on
screen I would forget about every other
actor that's important is your commands
a screen was a lot of good scary quinta
mando in the finale there's there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on in the finale but
one of the aspects as the main villain
is obviously looking for Matt Damon that
is the scariest part even though all
these other things will technically
sound scarier does it use a terrifying
got the scariest thing in the world is
not any like whatever you can think of
that's really terrifying it's nowhere
near as bad as finding out that [ __ ]
Kruger is after you yeah seria de
introduce this guy the character is an
animal like they introduce him he's
covered in a burlap cloak so he's like
half he's like Jesus Christ trying to
hide himself
the crab quit Jesus because he's covered
in like a burlap cloak so he's like half
of the scary drifter dude in a fantasy
movie like covered in the cloak with his
hood up and it's like what the [ __ ] he
got hiding under there but he's that guy
but if he were made out of like dirt and
[ __ ] chewed up bolts I'm so glad this
was rated R yeah I did not know it was
really I yeah i did not know his radar
when i watch it until I her to f words
with Matt Damon and I was like those in
rabun in rapid succession I one more
guess they don't cross the line with
anything like to violent or disturbing
yeah I got but you plug put it you can't
put a leash on on something like that
and they could still be scary make it so
via yeah this is because you could see
how they could have made this pg-13 but
it would not have been as cool but all
the teeth would be and the performance
of the villain it like of this guy was
so [ __ ] good yeah and I think only in
a rated r movie could it have been that
effect because they described him like
he's a guy who's like rape woman and
stuff like yes Gary mother fed he used
to be a TV producer he was the youngest
working TV producer in South Africa like
here a nice to do when he was 22 this is
true all the Toronto coakley reason to
see number 5 cinematography and editing
minging this movie was shot so [ __ ]
cool yeah the word to describe this
movie is cool yeah it is just so cool
know everything it does it's so cool on
Elysium but on earth it's too hot and
too crowded into shaky and too noisy
which is brilliant it seems obvious that
Elysium is going to be like you know on
a tripod like cameras on sticks
everything's very stable and then on
earth it's like everything's shaky cam
everything's yeah but it works because
it's like everything is really tight on
earth everything is really wobbly and
unstable on earth there's some
impressive ass shots to ya action at
times yeah yeah that's a really fast on
earth and so it's like I mean the action
when you like when you want to see it's
not so shaky that the action is just
like this garbled mess but it's like
when you are on earth everything feels
uncomfortable and you can feel just how
oppressive and unbearable this
overcrowded horrible [ __ ] places
that's just la I had to
and the editors of this movie because
again like I said this could they could
make this much longer and give more sort
of things to each you know different
story but I feel like the editors it
moves along really fast but it doesn't
feel like it was cut in a blender you
know it's like they really knew what
moments to keep what to say when to say
it how to frame it how to cut it yeah
and it moves along quickly but it even
just the right way it's like even the
style of the directing changes are lots
of the smile the way they're going to
capture is going to look totally
different they look the editing and the
story I'll meld together it's like you
set a level on it and that [ __ ] is like
plummet the bubbles in the magnificence
that shit's plum bro okuma risen to see
number 60 could actually in the fixed
one is not it there's an act [ __ ]
there's a lot of actions like it's not
filled with action but there's a there's
a lot of action and the action is so
[ __ ] cool yeah it's it's actually
felt the drama is felt it's not like
just a cool action scene and dramas felt
but also like the impact yeah all those
here every time someone blows up like
you sat next to me there were a number
of times rolled like whoa yeah it's like
the explosions have the white have the
right weight to them the boat like a gun
shots have the right way to them the
punches have the right way to them it's
like there isn't a point where just like
let's just have like everything blowing
up and everything being child with a
visual effects on it to like damn I hope
this gets an Oscar nomination they're
like gore gags and stuff that I wasn't
expecting that all look great and all
the machinery looks great its you know
you feel it fits great brilliantly like
like unapologetically realistic it's
like you don't get away with thinking Oh
violence is fun because you know because
there's so much of it it's just a
rollicking good time it's just like no
there's this [ __ ] hurts this [ __ ] hurts
people's limbs are on the opposite side
of the room from each other reason to
see number seven the production design
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah it's Neil be
new big dark gritty disgusting at times
but even beautiful like it's a weird
combination and well and there's like
that the tech to like he's got a very
specific looking and feel to the
machinery in his movies and
got this geometric industrial look to it
that feels like this is something that
could really be built exactly it's like
you look at this world and you're like
that whole thing they rigged up to his
spine the back you're like yeah this
looks like computer parts that somebody
I want that I know I do tell what I wish
someone could do that to me and
apparently gangsters in the future are
really good at surgery when they're high
I just saw this movie called a Pacific
Rim oh and I was thinking how cold the
Ruby to be like a sort of a human
version of that and I think in some ways
Matt Damon is partially their reason to
see number 8 the score I think this kind
of Hollywood [ __ ] epic music you know
what man I know it I know what happens a
lot of these days but when you crest
over some nasty looking city and all
yours burn like that's [ __ ] cool I
don't care like I love that drownings
and the score and the music actually has
a really good like connection to the
locale because everyone on Elysium is
listening to pleasant classical music
playing the background everything on
earth is like grungy and kind of
discordant split decisions Jodie Foster
mmm yeah she sucks in this movie oh just
sucks what is that accent it's like a
lofty high-class that's my point it's
like there's that accent it's likes
tracting as hell it's not quite French
it's like it's like French but I know
enough English and I've been around
enough Americans and enough English
people that my English act when I speak
English my accent is perfect I don't
really mind the accident uh probably
because this movie has sort of a
especially on Elysium it there's a very
sort of multicultural vibes and like you
know the president is likely says Indian
people are speaking French people are
speaking Spanish you know it's like it's
kind of a multicultural movie anyway I
hate to use this term but Jodi is
playing this she's playing like an
antagonist character and she feels like
she feels like she knows she's playing
an antec she's doing a little bit of
mustache twirling she kind of wasn't
even though she's a lady but she felt
well you know she felt a little a little
like ungentle and find myself wondering
am I not engaged by her performance
because she's not giving the best
performance or is it because the words
don't quite match her face and now I the
two are separate
was the former by the way runs consensus
Elysium is the reason movies are made
Elysium is the reason movies are made
movies are made for reasons and this is
the reason why news li li Geri's
consensus I see you cringing over there
but I don't give a [ __ ] I'm going with
move realism I don't give up I'm going
with the recent movies are made right
now Elysium is the recent movies are
made it's brad its gets got more brains
and guts than a lot of other big sci-fi
movies live big you know exploding
action movies it's awesome go check it
out Aaron's consensus feel good nib blue
Cup money's the focus sick whole [ __ ]
baguette zip [ __ ] [ __ ] make
the fist [ __ ] offense Elysium is the
reason movies are made no it's it's a
brilliant [ __ ] piece of work it's got
a its got a good mix of intelligence in
action like really genuine gripping
human drama and it's it's a thoroughly
satisfying summer action sci-fi movie
that's the whole review right then in
like 12 seconds alright guys thanks for
checking out our review for Elysium why
don't you go ahead scroll to that
comment box below and tell us what did
you think of Elysium and let's argue
about it and then once you're done with
that [ __ ] come on over here click this
button and see more episodes of reasons
to see and if you want to follow us on
twitter you can click this link right
here will follow you back that's what we
do and if you want to like us on
Facebook that would be very kind of you
and if you want to get up tighter to LA
if you want about tight and if you want
to get a bit every time a new reviewer
videos out sisas subscribe click on
Aaron's pecs he's been working it he's
been working he can finally bounce them
people just like Matt Damon I'm just
like nothing oh yeah pain & gain really
inspired me I haven't seen a single
movie since pain and gain I just been
hitting good hey Solly see him just now
yeah so that sentence is incorrect max
so now on the top side working out he's
gonna walk around with like a big robot
suit dude yeah be so cool if you can get
that Aaron ya know by the
the time I do an extra view I'm gonna
I'm gonna be a lot more small I'm gonna
be covered in hydraulics and we'll have
so much neck muscle you won't be able to
speak and then I'm gonna get leave yo
give James Franco's grill and [ __ ] in
and cornrows and tanning oil I was South
African again you're just gonna look
like a weird people it's going to be an
amalgamation of every movie I review
with you guys it's gonna be the picture
of dorian me oh i forgot i say something
bout Matt Damon I'd suck his dick
you